165° f for chicken minimum if your
recipe is calling for lower than that
find a new recipe you know there's
something just so entertaining about how
confidently incorrect people feel
comfortable being online like my man
opened up the video by labeling himself
as a microbiologist but didn't even take
7 Seconds to Google how pasteurization
works so for the benefit of all those
watching let's take those seconds shall
we and what do you know the very top
result explains pretty clearly that
pasteurization the bit that makes meat
safe to eat by killing off its bacteria
with heat to put it simply is a function
of both heat and time and hey look an
easy to follow graph that shows you how
long you need to hold chicken at
different temperatures for for the meat
to be equally safe boy that was
difficult I'm going to lay down now from
all that effort